je pense que nous étions fiers de notre
ville
c'était la
je dirais pas un souci
heureusement qu'on ne sait pas ce qui
nous attend
[Musique]
rien n'a plus jamais été pareil à
Lac-Mégantic
après cette terrible nuit du 5 au 6
juillet 2013
[Musique]
l'après
moi j'ai retrouvé mes citoyens engagés
prêts à
se reconstruire qui se sont tenus debout
à 80 ans retraités et maintenant loin
des projecteurs l'ancienne mairesse que
les trois Laroche jettent un regard
lucide sur les 10 dernières années quand
on vit ce moment-là quand on regarde
vers l'avant on se dit 10 ans c'est long
la reconstruction de l'humain ça ne se
passe pas de la même façon pour pour
chacun et il faut avoir confiance que le
temps avec le temps nous allons y
arriver nous nous posons des questions
comment comment on va survivre un
premier point de presse bouleversant qui
sera suivi d'une centaine d'autres en
deux ans jusqu'à la fin de son mandat en
2015 j'ai contacté la première ministre
madame Marois je réclame et le conseil
municipal l'équité pour l'acte Mégantic
des années que j'aime et que les trois
la roche n'oubliez pas ça c'est
important cette roche là où il sait un
jour arrêté le train la vie la musique
café était ici alors quand vous êtes ici
car les pertes ont été incommensurables
en plus des victimes des commerces de la
rue frontenacent ont été rasées par les
flammes puis il y a eu cette décision
difficile à prendre
le démolir les bâtiments encore debout
en raison entre autres de la
contamination des sols on ne meurt pose
plus la question on ne m'arrête plus sur
la rue pour me le dire mais je sais que
les gens entre eux s'emparent pour
certains ça a été de mauvaises décisions
pour d'autres ça a été une bonne
décision et pour moi la résilience des
méganticois
c'est leur courage
c'est leur solidarité
puis je dirais même la dignité dans
laquelle on a vécu les premières années
après la tragédie
représente clairement la force de
caractère et la résilience des gens de
Mégantic qui vont s'en sortir j'en suis
sûr on accueille la mairesse de Mégantic
madame Colette roi Laroche
courage qui inspiré bien les Québécois
et c'est encore le cas comme en témoigne
cette rencontre imprévue sur la rue
principale
[Musique]
d'une
j'en reviens pas comment vous avez été
extraordinaire vous êtes vraiment
gentils
merci est-ce que j'étais estomacée par
votre travail et du travail il en reste
encore beaucoup pas faire moi c'est
l'aspect là dans tout ce dossier là dans
les 10 années qui
je vous dirais j'allais dire choqué là
mais qui me choque le plus oui de voir
l'inaction du gouvernement face à la
réglementation ferroviale si à partir de
la tragédie de l'acte mégantique les
choses ne changent pas
il faut se poser des questions qu'est-ce
que ça va prendre pour que les choses
changent
un regard qui se veut bienveillant aussi
même si tout n'est pas parfait
comme c'est long train qui ne contourne
toujours pas centre-ville mais des
deuils étaient faits et se font toujours
puis j'aimerais que les gens pensent
qu'on n'est pas que de tragédie on est
du monde on est des personnes on est une
communauté qui s'est prise en main ici
Marie-Eve Laca Radio-Canada à
l'acnégantic
[Musique]